dit pas son nom
[Musique]
avant un concert donné ici pour les airs
vagabond on vous a trouvé une super
activités et ça se passe à la cavalerie
du moulin à usseau
ma main
et
si c'est la cavalerie du mot g c'est une
petite structure que j'ai créée en 2008
c'était pour proposer les activités de
pleine nature essentiellement donc ici
on pratique la randonnée c'est à dire
qu'on fait des activités sur les chevaux
mais en extérieur on ne fait pas
d'activité dans le manège ou en carrière
donc on fait des promenades pour tous
niveaux en fait des débutants des moyens
cavaliers des confirmés on regroupe les
gens par groupes de niveaux et on peut
faire une erreur 12h03 heure des demi
journée voire même des journées pique
nique avec une pause déjeuner au milieu
et après la particularité d'ici c'est
qu'on propose du voyage à cheval donc on
fait des séjours de 1 à 6 jours ici dans
la région et dans d'autres régions
également pour que les gens puissent
réserver et faire une activité fokine
téléphone souvent les gens regardent sur
mon site internet
il n'y a pas de programme défini pour
les heures de balade je fais vraiment
sur réservation et je regroupe les
personnes par groupe de niveau à
l'horaire qui leur convient donc on fait
des promenades en calèche ou des
animations on peut se déplacer chez les
personnes pour animer une fête ou
quelque chose comme ça et on peut
également associer la calèche à la
balade à cheval
quand on a des personnes qui veulent pas
monter à cheval par exemple si on n'a
pas pu mamie ou des gens de la famille
qui sont là et souvent c'est les
familles qui viennent et qui n'est pas
monté à choix ils peuvent quand même
profiter de cette activité en même temps
que les autres
alors moi le label sport nature c'est
tout récent en fait j'ai été labellisé
l'année dernière dans le poitou on va
dire
c'est pas très connu et c'était un bon
moyen aussi de faire découvrir aux gens
locaux qui peuvent faire des activités
avec des chevaux et qu'il ne pouvait pas
nécessairement bon cavalier pour faire
ça l'idée c'est vraiment de partager
l'activité avec un large panel de
personnes
[Musique]